alors comment critiquer quelqu'un je
pense que c'est quelque chose auquel on
devra beaucoup plus réfléchir ce
facilement la critique facile et c'est
pas facile de savoir quelle est la
meilleure façon de critiquer quelqu'un
donc je vous invite un peu à infléchir
et je veux un peu vous donnez un peu le
fruit d'une réflexion qui sont vachement
inspiré de 710 d'eau de jus la gale f1
chose à dire c'est que c'est très
tentant de voir critiquer quelqu'un et
parfois ça peut vraiment être très
important de critiquer quelqu'un
notamment par rouen
la personne en question est une personne
très influente qui a dit des choses pas
très correct ça peut être important de
du coup ici de corriger ça vous d'amener
la personne de s'améliorer ou à prendre
des actions pour corriger le tir ou pour
faire mieux dans l'avenir et du coup en
ce sens critique et est une phase
importante de l'amélioration de la
réflexion collective
mais le problème c'est curieusement on a
tendance à avoir d'autre objectif que
simplement cherché à améliorer la
réflexion collective au moment où on
veut critiquer quelqu'un et en
particulier souvent il ya beaucoup
d'énervement de m2 de mécontentement qui
tourne autour de l' envie de critiquer
quelqu'un et ça ça m'amène du coup aux
premiers points proposés par l'ua
ghallef que je trouve extrêmement
pertinents en général quand vous avez
envie de critiquer une quinte bonne idée
de ne pas le faire parce que bien
souvent on va dire des choses un petit
peu sous le coup de la colère ou de
l'agacement et ça ça va faire que on va
pas y mettre une critique et aux
bienveillantes a pas vraiment donné un
truc qui va plaire à l'autre et qui va
lui donner envie de s'améliorer
généralement on va me dire un truc un
peu blessant qui va plutôt avoir
tendance à donner envie à l'autre de se
reproduire sur lui même et de ne pas
écouter le fond de nos critiques
auxquelles je pense qu'il est très
important de faire attention à nos
motivations et si on sent que nos
motivations ne sont pas bonnes je pense
qu'une bonne raison pour ne pas dire
quoi que ce soit elle de ne pas émettre
à critique à ce moment là
peut-être attendre des moments où le
contexte sera plus favorable à émettre
la critique et sa tv quand ça arrive
particulièrement souvent lorsqu'il
s'agit de critiquer quelqu'un qui a fait
une vidéo qui a déjà reçu beaucoup de
critiques
c'est important je pense de se dire à ce
moment là que la personne que loi
critiquée c'est déjà fait énormément
critiqué souvent de manière violente et
que du coup une critique supplémentaires
aussi bienveillante soit elle ne sera
pas bien reçu ce sont là sera pas le
meilleur moment pour la faire et vont
peut-être mieux fait recette les tic
quelques jours après ou lorsque la
personne qui sera refait une cerisaie et
se sentira un peu mieux et plus prête à
recevoir en particulier la critique donc
la rance appareil ultra bizarre et ça
peut paraître très insatisfaisant voire
très frustrant ils sont vraiment là le
conseil le plus important à retenir de
cette vidéo c'est que en général il vaut
mieux ne pas m'être maîtres la critique
en tout cas pas au moment où on a envie
de les mettre
j'ai dit comme on l'a vu en introduction
de cette vidéo parfois ça reste très
utile d'apporter sa pierre à l'édifice à
l'amélioration de la réflexion
collective en émettant une critique de
telle ou telle personne et à ce moment
là je pense qu'il est très utile de bien
réfléchir à ce qu'on fait en particulier
d'appliquer un truc que j'ai découvert
en cours d'improvisation théâtrale qui
est le principe cookies lemon cookies
donc l'idée c'est qu'on va commencer par
quelque chose de gentil à dire quelque
chose qui est tu as pris ensemble est un
compliment ou quelque chose qui
correspond à dire que on est d'accord
sur le fond avec l'autre personne qui a
vraiment quelque chose de commun et
qu'on n'est pas juste dans l'opposition
l'idée étant vraiment de mettre l'autre
dans des prédispositions où il sera le
plus à même de recevoir la critique et
de l'exploiter pour qu'ensuite faire
quelque chose qui utilisent cette
critique vous pour aller mieux dans le
sens parlant de réflexion collective
donc d'abord essayé de mettre un climat
où on va bien débattre donc c'est le
premier coup qui ensuite on peut émettre
le la critique donc passé au lemon ça
risque de cliquer un petit peu mais ça
ça soit très utile en fait pour
s'améliorer collectivement et enfin on
peut finir avec une deuxième couche de
cookies l'idée étant de laisser l'autre
sur une très bonne note pour qu'elles se
disent qu'ils
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant et que
c'est passé d'agréables et pour l'amener
à vouloir réfléchir ensuite à la
critique qui a été émise et surtout ne
pas laisser l'autre sur une mauvaise
note sur une mésentente désaccord qui
donnerait l'impression que la critique
étaient malveillantes ou trop frontal
donc ça c'est le cookie limon clicquot
show va être un excellent conseil à
donner pour essayer de mieux émettre des
critiques des critiques qui seront en
particulier efficace c'est-à-dire pas
des critiques justes pour exprimer un
mécontentement des critiques qui sont
vraiment là pour chercher à améliorer la
discussion où la réflexion collective
il me semble vraiment que cette idée
d'avoir un cookie les mannequins qui est
vraiment quelque chose de bien plus
efficace en pratique lorsque j'aurai
tendance à vraiment vous encourager à c
y est constamment d'avoir cette approche
qui élimine cookies alors quelques notes
supplémentaires notamment au moment de
démettre la critique en tant que têtes
donc la partie lemon lorsque on aimait
la critique c'est intéressant de
présenter sa davantage sous forme d'
opportunités d'amélioration
que de fautes particules si on parle de
faute au moment de la critique
ça augmente beaucoup une chance qu'une
autre personne va se sentir vexé va se
recroqueviller sur elles-mêmes et ne va
pas profiter de la discussion pour
s'auto améliorer donc remplacé à chaque
fois la notion de photos d'erreur de
responsabilité ou de culpabilité par une
notion de marge de progression
d'opportunités pour vraiment devenir
bien meilleur et en particulier avoir
des actions beaucoup plus bénéfique
bienveillante et constructive
autre aspect qui me semble vraiment très
intéressant insisté sur le fait que les
conseils clinton sont des choses qui
sont extrêmement difficiles à suivre et
que par exemple assez soit peut-être que
nous on n'y arrive pas encore ou quelque
chose comme ça ou que très peu de gens
il y arrive mais vraiment montrer qu'il
ya un effort à faire avec eux c'est pas
juste une critique en disant il suffit
de faire 6 et tout ira mieux souvent les
conseils qui sont vraiment constructif
ça consiste à dire qu'il faut faire
énormément de choses qui sont très
compliquées et 6 du coût important
d'insister sur le fait que les choses
sont compliquées
encore une fois pour que l'autre évite
de se vexer et comprennent que les
choses sont compliquées
on va insister sur le fait que souvent
faire des bonnes choses c'est compliqué
troisième petite remarque essaie
d'éviter de paraître au dessus de
l'autre essayait d
tu es à tout prix de donner l'impression
qu'on est un enseignant et dit à l'autre
exactement ce qu'il va faire et que de
l'autre on doit appliquer machinalement
ce qui va être fait je pense que les
critiques sont beaucoup plus constructif
beaucoup plus bénéfique vous efficace
lorsque on insiste sur le fait que les
choses sont difficiles et que nous avec
le peu d'expérience et d'expertisé que
l'on a on a l'impression que avec aussi
avec tous les marqueurs de me laisser
épistémique dont on a déjà parlé que la
personne doit faire mieux ou améliorer
ses propos en faisant si vous ça et
peut-être on se trompe ce genre de
modestie et pis les mythes permet
souvent de bien me faire passer une
critique moi ça fait quand même pas mal
d'informations sur cette vidéo il invita
milliers tout ça mais ça fait peut-être
un peu trop de choses à retenir donc
pourquoi ans et je pense que c'est très
important doit obtenir des points très
très simple le premier c'est que si vous
voulez critiquer quelqu'un il est bon de
se rajouter un réflexe de se dire mais
non enfin sinon je vais pas critiquer la
personne du moins il faut vraiment une
très bonne raison pour critiquer la
personne est une très très bonne raison
c'est pas juste je suis énervé ça doit
être la capacité à vraiment aider
l'autre à s'améliorer
et si jamais on veut se lancer dans ce
genre de critiques
je conseille très vivement le cookie
lemon cookies c'est à dire commencer
d'abord par une remarque bienveillante
typiquement un compliment ou le fait que
partagent les mêmes objectifs qui
agissent comme ça ensuite et m la
critique en tant que tel le lemon et
ensuite finir absolument sûr un croquis
pour laisser une autre sur une bonne
remarque une bonne conclusion qui sera
du coup beaucoup plus motivant pour
l'autre pour qu'ils se mettent à
réfléchir à comment prendre en contre
cette critique pour s'améliorer